yeah welcome to this video playing a
blitz game against GM lingo from Norway
life you understand yeah played it
before him some crazy some crazy a
Philly door okay the names oh and let's
see if I can play into my recommended
book line going for the hoopla and
indeed we get to this opening I'm in
this line and this is this has been
played many times 92 hmm yeah also a
move but ran off it's not a camel move
him I prepare a 5 immediately like to
I'd like to play f5 here as soon as
possible it simply helps to mobilize
blacks forces I know it looks a bit
weird to trade this supposedly bad
bishop against the night but it's still
good because um it's more important to
make sure that black has enough space
for his pieces ok Knight f6 mmm now I
don't want no g5 should I prepare i
might play a form i see
okay it's it's not such a big deal i 95
95 was an idea maybe Queen d7 this was
was my point after takes I can take with
the Queen and he can't go to e6 but
after the traits it doesn't matter so
much the night only six is mostly a
problem with Queens on with Queens
offered some am an annoyance but not
fatal so now take take it and yeah then
he goes to e6 mmmm
ok
yeah 96
you're taking on Air Force really it's
really a move that helps him
tremendously don't want to do that maybe
this one
this was my DM free if I for the night
yeah i can simply play that move
I need to quickly get towards e-form
night c7 I can just go go away with the
rook maybe it's not so bad maybe it's
not so bad
maybe I can just detect e5
it doesn't have such a guru such great
squares I need to play g6 this is very
important get rid of this cramping pawn
and maybe try to exchange this look for
the f1 rook would be a enormously
helpful let's try to get rid of this
now G fog I just kill go to e7 knutson
our weight you can give this check
anyway mmm you can take h7 Soneji father
I must I must change I must return him
you're him yeah what I want nonsense why
did I allow that for Christ's sake
unnecessary brilliant
check
check
check
yeah it's um it's um it's a shame
reading I really like the position but
it has simply plated battling
time warning
check
okay black resigns I what a crap game
right when I was I think out of out of
the woods I gave it away it's clear that
white has pressure and somehow it was
around here I'm perfectly all right I
don't believe that why should have
anything especially in ya g6 now some
eg6 and not waste any more time now I
can take and king of 7ab the compass
already for preferring black hair this
doesn't surprise me check but this was
really terrible allowing all that year
check it here i need to play age six and
not rupee aid yeah just this one what
what's what's so great here
yeah i can continue it's not a big deal
what is what interests me is I mean
besides my bad play in the end game here
really curious about the opening this
one
we are quickly seven and then f form
yeah the computer suggests this one
quite interesting sacrificing a poem
yeah this is interesting he's got a very
bad bishop some black has some decent
play on the light squares like here yeah
interesting not sure if it's convincing
but it's interesting yeah this
definitely was better for wide
can maybe that's sh6 em but still f for
now this is click on 96 maybe this could
be a good idea
yeah maybe this is the point to control
f form not sure still this 96 is not
such a big issue Queen here I also have
this move to exchange a knight coming
here this is about equal according to
company it's definitely better than the
game now always very complex middle
games here thanks for watching